eu queria agradecer o convite que o
telex e se esse isso e eu me perguntava
então o que querem que eu e vale dizer
ah ea resposta foi pode falar sobre o
terceiro tem a ver com artistas a e eu
fiquei um pouco baralhado eles mas é que
a universidade não são estanques e é
sobre isso que eles querem ouvir falar
não sair vou conseguir
e então por exemplo como ele ficou lá
que é como é que eu em 15 minutos porém
25 anos do que eu fiz não sejam crianças
ao menos o meu patrão em ataque o elenco
pensa não há intenção não é cocaína
certamente muitas das coisas que eu fiz
vocês conhecem
qual foi o melhor peça de teatro que
vocês viram nos vossos últimos tempos
podem ter sido há muito tempo mas cujo
marcou ninguém vai até a qual foi o
grande espetáculo que vocês viram que
não são exequíveis que não seja música
antiga da conversa da treta
estas duas coisas são talvez duas coisas
mais importantes que aconteceram nesses
últimos anos
a conversa da treta foi a revolução
daquilo que é o teatro comercial que
isto inclui então não presta
foi a primeira coisa que ouvi de um
jornalista
então para aí há as que têm público não
presta a ato que tem pouco público é
subsidiava altamente interessante e os
mesmos paradigmas foram crescendo
crescendo crescendo e eu fui esquecendo
disto e fui fazendo o que eu fui fazendo
junto a dois é usar o eram no rio fez
seus gênios junta josé pedro gomes e
antónio feio porque eu estava
fazer o tom um dos grupos mais
conhecidos e que o a mais 12 anos faz em
portugal e em contra estes dois senhores
que contava uma história do teatro em
portugal não vai a lado nenhum
nós não conseguimos promover ninguém
lhes liga nenhuma e eu sei do grande
auditório do centro cultural lá e fui
pequeno auditório onde eu estava a fazer
um espetáculo como é que nós nos
encontrávamos no bairro e não vai dizer
mas não é possível nós temos 1200
pessoas no grande auditório estava cheio
e você está em 500 no pequeno auditório
que também está aí
portanto não é o vasco nós dizemos que o
teatro não tem público algum teatro não
tem público nomeadamente aquela que a
subsidiária tem sempre muito pouco
público o que nós fizemos em termos eu
juntos é pedro antônio e começa a
promover teatro e fazer digressões pelo
país então estamos a senhora qualquer
coisa como há 20 anos atrás e começamos
este salvas
vamos fazer tudo e simplesmente teatro
comercial é assumidamente teatro para o
público desde aí nunca mais parámos hora
que o zé pedro antónio depois com uma
série de outros artistas como miguel
guilherme
o bruno no lugar é mais recentemente a
maria rueff de bola e salvas tem estado
permanentemente saiu isso que nós
fizemos em que éramos o teatro de outra
maneira
e aí começam os fizessem desfizessem
desfizesse e foi isso que nós fizemos
ou seja não ficarmos parados não
ficarmos sentados
experimentávamos a em carros estavam se
tivermos o público
isso é o que eu faço no meu dia a via
quando estoura o ao todos os nossos
projetos têm um centro atrás qualquer
coisa e sim as pessoas não vão e sim o
público não gosta para que nós vivemos
do público e dos bilhetes estes exames
são permanentemente problemas que nós
temos que transformar
coisas não é isso são sempre aventuras
então o que nós fizemos procuramos
concluí-la procuramos projetos
interessantes fomos buscar o que de
melhor se fazia no mundo vai lá buscar o
morrissey já trouxemos de portugal
escrito e diziam isso é muito comercial
não vai correr bem pois na altura
tivemos um jornalista que escreveu no
centro cultural de belém mais um fiasco
em portugal uma coisa que era muito
comercial porque na altura uma crise
pesada que tinha feito uma coreografia
do screen actors com o papa
versátil e coisa que foi muito bem ali
as coisas não estão para ser uma tarde
no centro cultural online
a letra é crítica em que conseguiu fazer
um dia antes do espetáculo ter
acontecido que não estava mas é verdade
então estava uma fila inteira no centro
cultural oboé jornal aberto e eu ia
dizer para deve ter sido o único tipo
que eu conheço no mundo e conseguiu
fazer uma crítica ao espetáculo que
ainda não aconteceu
tu não conseguiste ver o jogo consiste
criticar eu estou sempre num isso
faltando sempre qualquer coisa eu tenho
sempre um problema qualquer
e vamos que vamos vamos vamos
ultrapassar livre já te argentina onde
um dos espetáculos mais notáveis da
minha vida que eu não sei se algum de
vocês viram não esteve no porto foi à
guardia
depois mais tarde um outro chamado força
bruta e ainda o musical dos chutes e
pontapés não sai falando em ter uma
oportunidade em lisboa assistir a este
espetáculo será que alguém tenha visto a
banda estrela não alguém que aconteceu
nós estávamos na argentina e depois de
vermos um é o espetáculo tal paramos
também com um problema que não há sala
em portugal para fazer esse espetáculo
no cabo
estamos num carro temos que conseguir
fazer então viemos no avião e eu eo
nosso diretor técnico diretor
igual a esse construímos um teatro
somos malucos sentimo nós vamos
conseguir fazer um teatro mas no avião a
viagem foi longa
nós fomos fazendo os que se todos do
teatro e uma semana depois estavam sem
luz hoje estávamos com engenheiros e com
empresas a construir um teatro
sozinhos não conseguimos foi preciso
encontrar um patrocinador e nas é um
enjôo é toyota box uns passos quis ter
três anos esteve três anos em alcântara
e assim conseguimos trazer o espetáculo
está sentindo e conseguimos fazê los ea
coisa ficou tão bem que conseguimos
fazê-lo lisboa madrid e barcelona o meio
e sucesso sempre reconstruir os teatros
e se nós não tivéssemos vindo da
argentina
isso nós não tivéssemos conseguido fazer
o teatro para fazer o espetáculo vida
normal e que o que nós temos feito mal
ao passo que nem por isto passa por
encontrar coisas em que acreditamos que
entre as costas somos sem fios
o projeto em nossa equipe visitante e
que lutamos para fazê-los não muito
contente com tudo isto e como a obra
desde o início
o meu pai trabalhava na etapa quando
tudo isso começou eu tenho a sorte de
eliza
então o que eu tinha eu tinha sempre a
hipótese está no estrangeiro
estamos a falar há 30 anos atrás e
começar a questionar mas por que estamos
fazendo em portugal é que nós não
conseguimos fazer isto porque os grandes
musicais não vai encarar porque só fala
música nunca ninguém tinha convidado por
vídeo e aí que nós a partir do nosso
escritório começamos né
confira a previsão em quem o chicago um
desastre brutal
prevemos um milhão de euros em três
semanas
nem eu sabia o que isso era na altura
uma luta não imagina foi o inferno aqui
o escritório durante um herói e tentar
comprar mas compramos empréstimos podres
principal mensagam trazemos o caps e não
quero isso temos todos os
acho que alguma vez aconteceu no coliseu
de lisboa e no coliseu do porto
qualquer coisa como 200 mil espectadores
que não é necessário 200 mil
espectadores nem mesmo a féria quando
escreve mais um milhão de pessoas viram
consegue manter o mesmo também escreve é
impossível não há pessoas preferem estas
coisas e nós fomos fazendo tem uma misa
devem ter visto não voltar a fazer
no entanto como estávamos muitos gatos
começamos a descobrir o que os
estrangeiros criam então vamos o fato
para o estrangeiro
não somos nós que fazemos sozinhos
felizmente hoje há dezenas de empresas a
trabalhar nesta área e há dezenas de
empresas é o vapor que é português para
o estrangeiro e cultura que ele tem que
fazer casa é difícil fazer no
estrangeiro é mais difícil não é que eu
consigo fazer só para vocês terem uma
idéia
nestes últimos 30 dias fez 17 concertos
no estrangeiro porque o fato está nela
está na moda porque é bom porque é
bonito porque nós porque são coisas
fantásticas nós fazemos também em termos
culturais para o estrangeiro
hoje apresentamos um artista brasileiro
apresentamos um dos pontos que está
permanentemente no estrangeiro por isso
é que nós não vimos em portugal é muito
tá
trabalhamos com os improváveis e carlos
moura e ainda temos uma orquestra que
tem uma base num teatro em lisboa
fazemos agenciamento tudo isto criamos
pacote ainda temos alguns grupos
estrangeiros não estão aqui apresentamos
um grupo argentino chamado tango passión
com quem fazemos petacchi no mundo
inteiro e um outro francês com os
campeões do mundo sapateavam mas constam
portuguesa são os tempos factory estão
neste momento na china durante dez anos
como português devido é que vem também
algumas das coisas doces há uns anos
atrás e esta talvez seja também uma das
histórias da minha vida
estávamos no escritório e dissemos já
fazem isto não fazemos exposições mas
nós temos instituições exposições a
gente quer fazer e acho que dentro do
grupo de trabalho a um totalmente o
campeonato em star wars
eu nem fazia na época da guerra de
nervos de ser você estudar aqui o e com
clay é fanático nesta questão é ninguém
vai ganhar nenhuma vamos começar a
mandar e mails pós lucas e não vamos ter
a resposta sobre quem diz não não
acredito muito em nós não vai ser fácil
porque nós começamos a melhorar em maio
e que existe pois estávamos em são
francisco nos caiu ao ter land na casa
dos jogos lucas que convençam que minha
coisa que eu queria fazer era tirá tudo
500 armas e montar uma exposição com
tudo que fez na vida dela
a princípio serão então éramos malucos
número três meses depois de pé
cinco meses depois estávamos a fazer é o
esgoto cinco anos depois teremos
concluído toda a europa com três milhões
de visitantes à exposição voltou para os
estados unidos como sabem os que estão
mais atentos e ligados a essas coisas
realiza a i comprou a lucasfilm
importante aumentar novamente para lavar
agora estamos no processo de conversão
ao islamismo em que agora tem muito mais
algumas das conquistas pateras lá é ver
se conseguimos fazer uma exposição
faltou vínhamos no avião e terminarmos o
australian open 2010
é o que nós fizemos
temos que encontrar outra e então surgiu
mas vamos escrever uma carta um
irmãozinho para o governo americano e
vamos tentar fazer a nasa
a versão da europa para a nasa
essa gente não vai conseguir vai ser
difícil pois aqui tem três meses depois
criamos uma exposição em madri
já vemos a voltar à europa tome com ela
e só não fazemos em portugal que não há
espaço para montar não acreditam pois
não mas não há poucos pouco espaço que
nós temos um custo mais turquia
qualquer espaço na europa inteira junta
às vezes não há vontade de fazer coisas
essa é questão recentemente que nós
temos feito
gerimos o auditório dos oceanos está no
casino lisboa
compramos o teatro futebol e procuro
mandar abaixo para fazer mais um hotel e
nós achamos que não chegava e os nossos
têm a ver com isto
o quadro foi escrever duas coisas que eu
acho que é importante na vida e hoje
penso aqui é que muitos anos e sei que
fazia algum sentido falar sobre isto nós
temos que acreditar
temos que ir e temos que sonhar
vocês ficam mais pênis era isto escreveu